[Music]
hello there December is upon us once
again the last chance for game
Publishers to grab our attention Before
Christmas arrives after the staggeringly
packed October and November months
things have cooled off a little but
there's still some great premium reduced
price and free games worthy of your
attention so for the final time in 2023
here's the best games releasing this
month followed by some terrible dad
jokes the highlight of December is
Avatar Frontiers of Pandora a game about
those blue people from two of the
highest grossing movies of all time
Avatar and Avatar way of the water a
thing to know right away is that the
story here is a standalone experience
but it does link to the movies kind of
like the Hogwarts game earlier in the
year if you know the subject matter
you'll get more out of the experience
but it isn't completely necessary I've
been lucky enough to play avatar for a
few hours and without a doubt Far Cry
Gamers will feel right at home with this
one gameplay-wise we are a n
playing in first person as we go through
their trials such as choosing your own
Mount mine here is called Carol from
there the world is fully explorable as
the war with the sky people begins
during our playthrough we can harness
both na'vi and human Weaponry personally
I found using a bow and staying as
stealthy as possible was the most
satisfying way to play but when
outnumbered and outgunned switching to
the heavy machinery to tear through the
more tanky enemies was also quite
satisfying this is a Ubisoft game so
expect the usual incredibly filled open
world with numerous side quests like
saving this beast from captivity I
checked if we had to save him and no we
do not surprisingly this Ubisoft open
world game is not made by the team I
expected it's actually made by the
people who brought us the division
Avatar frontiers of Pandora releases on
December 7th on PS5 Xbox series and
PC the next game I was excited to talk
about is Disney Dreamlight Valley mainly
because it was intended to be a
free-to-play game in the style of Animal
Crossing but based around Disney
properties instead but alas the decision
was made to keep Dreamlight Valley a
premium experience which leaves early
access on December 5th although it will
retain its lower digital price of around
$30 us and £25 here in the UK we arrive
in this game world to find almost all
Disney characters have lost their
memories so we move in operating as a
light Sim in which the clock on your
console or PC is synced to the time in
game we customize and build everything
from our own character our home and we
even do the gardening the world then
opens up and unlocks new biomes related
to Disney and Pixar characters
eventually leading to a bustling town of
inhabitants there's currently 41
characters to discover ranging from Buzz
to Moana from Wreck-It Ralph to Mike
Wazowski with more characters added
regularly if a Zen life Sim based on
Disney properties is your kind of a
thing look out for Dreamlight Valley on
December
5th okay over to the free games for the
month and first up is an experience
which refers to itself as the world's
greatest free-to-play combat game show
this is the finals and over 7.5 million
players downloaded and played the beta
last month and the game is still
confirmed to release in 2023 the finals
is a first-person shooter inspired by
movies like Hunger Games and Gladiator a
spectacle of combat set up as a TV show
contestants enter the arena but instead
of the usual modes you find in a
first-person shooter the finals changes
things up the cash out mode sets four
teams of three players against each
other to grab as much cash and Bank it
before the timer hits zero but during
that time other teams can steal your
money making for frantic scenarios of
defense and attack constantly arising
another amazing element about the vinyls
is its nonon fully destructible Arena
hypothetic ically if you see money on
the top of a building you could choose
to knock that building down the finals
is also a class-based shooter with light
medium and heavy options which literally
dictate how big your character is and
therefore how big their hitbox is the
smaller classes are faster and more
agile while the bigger ones are more
tanky and can take more damage the
finals is set to release any day now all
we know is 2023 is the year it's coming
and as I'm writing this it's likely the
game awards will give us the information
about the release date so look out for
that on December 7th the finals the
first person extraction shooter will
release on PS5 Xbox series and
PC another free-to-play game out right
now is Hades star dark nebula definitely
not one for everyone it's for a certain
Niche audience dark nebula is a strategy
game which evolves into a multiplayer
tactical battler the premise is to build
an Empire to use resources and travel
the Galaxy exploring and taking over
other planets in order to build your
civilization we begin in our own yellow
star Galaxy and slowly develop drop
ships battleships and Interstellar
travel many of the missions involve
realtime countdowns and waiting for
timers to refresh like a mobile game
giving Hades star a drop in for a few
minutes check on a few things and then
come back a few hours later kind of vibe
once you get to grips with everything
you'll leave your yellow Star
constellation and Venture into the red
star space which is the home of PVP
again against or alongside 20 other
players do you choose diplomacy or War
Hades star dark nebula is out right now
on Playstation Xbox PC and mobile I owe
you a quick update on a game I showed
you last month side bullet an
interesting take on Battle Royale in a
2d Sid scroller following its release
only a matter of days later it was
officially delisted and shut down I've
emailed PlayStation and the devs and yet
have no information on this I have no
idea why it shut down but side bullet
live for a few days and now it's gone
forever
rip Halloween may have been and gone but
horror is still coming in December the
much loved Five Nights at Freddy's
Series has another VR Edition help
wanted to a unique PlayStation VR2
miname Extravaganza designed for
replayability this won't be a oneandone
six confirmed modes are backstage Faz
Cade staff only food prep ticket booth
and a special category containing new VR
versions of Five Nights at Freddy's
sister location we've been told each
playthrough will be quite unique as
different events will be triggered in
any scenario from going backstage as a
VIP with Rox and wolf to playing as one
of the security staff themselves help
wanted to will add to the extensive Laur
of Five Nights at Freddy's in the most
of interactive platforms and with psvr
2's haptics this may be the most
terrifying of them all help wanted to
drops on Playstation VR2 on December
14th and it's expected to come to PC VR
soon
after a unique game I think is worth
your attention is steam World build
which combines two genres an in-depth
City Builder by day and a Dungeon
Crawler By Night steam World brings us
robots and westons it's quite strange
but it works and first asks us to build
a town managing costs and challenging
your funu skills soon the town grows to
include Rail and other Industries and
all the while you're effectively the
mayor deciding where to expand and what
to spend money on all that wealth is
thanks to your minds under your feet and
that's where the gameplay changes down
here your riches are under threat from
creatures of the darkness and a tower
defense Style game mode begins play long
enough and you'll evolve everything
including a science program which comes
with its own rocket ship you're going
into Stella if steam World build is your
jam it drops on December 1st on the
PlayStations the Xboxes the PC and the
switch next I intended to tell you about
a game set in the world of the Lord of
the Rings Return to Maria takes the
Middle Earth created by Tolen and builds
a survival crafting game upon it from
building bases to crafting armor to
upgrading your pickaxe to mine
increasingly rare ores the thing is the
Xbox version has been delayed and the PC
version which released last month
averages a score of four out of 10 so
maybe this is not the Lord of the Rings
game we deserve or at least not
yet other games dropping this month are
Grand blue Fantasy Versus Rising on PC
and PlayStation on December 14th the
well respected 2.5d fighting series
Warhammer 40K Rogue Trader is this
month's RPG releasing on December 7th
and surprisingly the biggest game news
of the month is not actually a game
releasing it's an announcement in early
December Grand Theft Auto 6 will be
officially announced which has likely
scared off a few games planning their
own announcements I intend to cover GTA
6 for the next few years so do me a
favor and check back if that's your kind
of thing later in December okay I've
been in your ear holes far too long
let's end this with some terrible dad
jokes why can't you hear a pterodactyl
going to the bathroom cuz the p is
silent it's old but it's gold something
christmy to end what did one snowman say
to the
other do you smell carrots sorry that's
Dreadful I'm Adam you're awesome I'll
see you next
time